visiblement donc c'est twilight qui a
été déclaré vainqueur par ko face à ces
deux outsideurs en ce jour de sortie
cinéma des nouveaux invités vont venir
me rejoindre donc sur le plateau du 7-8
tout d'abord loup demontis mme bonsoir à
vous je vous en prie venez vous
installer sur ce plateau avec votre
guitare auteur compositeur vos
références johnny cash bruce springsteen
également on va reparler de rock
vous l'aurez compris on parlera aussi de
hip hop avec deux autres invités qui
s'installe sur le plateau qui viennent
s'installer
venez je vous en prie sandrine hector
tout d'abord qui est coordinatrice
communication culturelle sur la
communauté d'agglomération de
saint-quentin bonsoir à vous et puis à
frédéric lignol responsable du service
jeunesse à guyancourt on va parler et
des hip hop gay games qui s'organise sur
votre commune et également des
initiations urbaine parce que ça c'est
l'ensemble de l'opération qui se déroule
jusqu'en juin 2013
les hip hop game pour débuter c'est quoi
les hippos games c'est un renouveau du
battle en réalité le concept du battle
maintenant est plutôt connu il y en a un
peu partout
l'idée c'était de trouver quelque chose
qui pouvait faire évoluer la danse et
notamment la danse hip hop et donc on
travaille avec un chorégraphe qui
s'appelle romuald brizolier et qui a mis
au point un spectacle vivant à base de
danse hip hop mais qui mêle
l'improvisation donc qui fait appel à
des choses plus profondes et moins il ya
moins de joutes
c'est vraiment d'intégrer spectacle on
envoie quelques images c'est un
spectacle c'est très chorégraphié ses
traits de bresse un vrai spectacle pour
le public il ya un enjeu de taille tout
de même pour pour les groupes qui
participent
celui qui remporte le concours sera
accompagné par les partenaires culturels
de la communauté d'agglomération pour
monter et diffuser son projet de
création exactement les partenaires de
la communauté d'agglomération
s'associent pour accompagner
la troupe gagnantes afin de le calme est
au point un spectacle qui sera diffusée
notamment à la ferme de bel ébat dans le
cadre de sa programmation de l'année
prochaine et pour ceux qui veulent en
savoir plus sur ces hip hop game on en
regarde quelques images un petit clip et
on se retrouve ensuite sur ce plateau
quelques images de ce qui attend le
public qui viendra le 17 novembre à
guyancourt et tout ça est dans le cadre
des pulsations urbaine sandrine hector
ce qu'un fil rouge sur l'année jusqu'en
juin 2013 c'est la deuxième édition pour
pour l'agglomération
l'objectif c'est quoi de toucher tout ce
qui concerne la culture urbaine pas
seulement la danse d'ailleurs pas
seulement la danse le hip hop est temps
en effet lascaux considère en premier ce
qu'on entend le premier dans la culture
urbaine mais le slam le théâtre le
stand-up humour le graffiti le manga
parce que finalement c'est une culture
qui touche un certain nombre de gens
assez large une génération la culture
urbaine c'est les années 80 mais c'est
jusqu'à aujourd'hui ça a quand même
concerner toute cette génération de gens
et puis également
c'est une culture qui exprime beaucoup
de choses dynamique qui touche beaucoup
la jeunesse donc c'est un vrai vrai
projet à 51,2 ligne pour parler à la
jeunesse de ce territoire les hip hop
game 6 a eu des ateliers d'initiation
aussi on envoie quelques images on
partiront sur alors de ces ateliers l'un
de ces stages tout à l'heure à travers
un reportage de johanna soudry on aurait
tout de même demandé à vous de mon
disque et en plateau avec nous c'est
tout ont recours on va le voir tout à
l'heure le hip hop les cultures urbaines
ce ça vous parle
oui parce que moi ce que j'en tendre ce
que
nos invités ici sur le plateau c'est
qu'ils m'ont culture et c'est ça qui est
important c'est que toutes expressions
musicales et artistiques où il ya aussi
de la culture de dans les sas et voilà
c'est pour les futures générations ces
voix là c'est les traditions dire qu'ils
vont passer tradition de demain moi
c'est ce mot là que je retiens plus que
le format par lui-même qui évidemment
touches différentes personnes plus ou
moins mais on en a besoin le besoin de
tout ce soir qu'on soit époque cette
façon c'est la culture c'est de là qu'il
est important de vous y intéresser tous
les territoires de saint-quentin toutes
les villes de saint quentin en yvelines
sont concernés 25 25 rendez vous sur
onze lieux oui quasiment il ya du de
l'humour à la ferme du mousseau de la
danse contemporaine d'un chorégraphe
kader attou au prisme du stand-up
attrape du hip hop à la merise attrape
également s'est ouvert à tous à la ferme
de bel ébat sont ouverts à tous ah oui
c'est tout déjà on est jeune on est
jeune à partir de jeu jusqu'à quand ces
jeunes dans les années 80 et qu'on a
aujourd'hui c'est un le hip hop fêtera
ses 30 ans l'année prochaine donc déjà
le territoire je pense sera à nouveau
associé sans doute que pulsations
urbaine saison 3 sera aussi l'occasion
de poursuivre cette mise en valeur de
cette expression culturelle assez forte
et puis oui on est jeune et puis on a
aussi des enfants qui peuvent aller voir
de la danse hip hop
écoutez du théâtre fait par des gens qui
ont voilà qui ont un lien avec la vie
qui ont un lien avec le graffiti les
couleurs c'est une autre façon
d'approcher la culture et je rejoins ce
que dit notre invité du plateau c'est
une culture à partager pour tous et à
bien ancrée sur ce territoire à 51 ans
nevin qui a vu beaucoup beaucoup de
générations de gens autour de la culture
urbaine qui aujourd'hui sont
effectivement très connus on va
persister tout va largement contribuer
effectivement à cette culture urbaine
pulsations urbaine c'est jusqu'en juin
2013 et il y a donc les hip hop game ce
spectacle ce 17 novembre il ya eu des
stages d'initiation on en a parlé on
part donc sur l'un de ces stages c'était
il ya quelques jours un sujet de jouer
soudry
non
d'habitude idriss da silva donne des
cours de hip hop
aujourd'hui c'est lui l'élève il est
venu découvrir le concept des hypothèses
on a entendu parler en effet pour voir
aujourd'hui la musicalité le style le
groupe le 6 minutes sans les hip hop
games ont été créés par romuald
brizolier champion du monde de hip hop
en 2009
cette année le concept s'installe à
saint quentin en yvelines dans le cadre
des pulsations urbaine ou thématiques
chères à l'agglomération à magny les
hameaux johanna faye a proposé un stage
d'initiation au hip hop game ce concept
durant tout un après-midi c'est s'amuser
ne surtout pas se juger et juste
s'écouter
et pas voir leurs bêtes acceptait de
journée
dedans c'est quoi ton général il ya
quatre groupes ils sont composés de
quatre personnes et en fait ces quatre
personnels vont faire tour à tour des
égouts des oeufs
les équipes s'affrontent lors d'un show
en plusieurs épreuves improvisé avec
l'autre joué autour d'un objet l'ipo
games recherche une dimension théâtrale
dans la danse sur trois musiques avoir
trois gestuelle différentes trois ans
tension du compte pas personnages
différents et ensuite quand la musique
switch pouvoir suit ce personnage le hip
hop game ce concept une performance à mi
chemin entre battle les créations